they've continued at the world economic
Forum here is video of European Union
commissioner Vera girova explaining how
Twitter and Elon must comply must comply
that is very scary must
our message was clear we have the rules
which has to which have to be complied
with and otherwise there will be
sanctions
[Music]
I think that the confidence has been
weakened
and I I had quite a high level of
confidence when it comes to Twitter I
have to say that we worked with
knowledgeable people with the lawyers
with the sociologists who understood
that they have to
behave in some decent way not to cause
really big harm to the society I always
felt that this this notion of
responsibility was that so this is what
I don't feel from uh Elon Musk
personally
it's rather extraordinary I mean when
these people when they say something
everything that they say is the reverse
of the truth that's like the Trudeau
Gavin Newsom situation everything they
say just listen to what they say and
assume that the reverse is true she she
wants Twitter to behave responsibly well
Twitter was silencing the hunter Biden
laptop and Twitter was hiding uh the
covid Skeptics by Shadow Banning and
banning people outright and suspending
accounts and all of those things
[Music]
foreign